L'un des fruits, ou l'un des aspects du fruit de l'esprit, ces fruits singuliers évoqués ici par l'apôtre Paul, c'est la paix.
Et comme c'est un fruit du Saint-Esprit des dieux, c'est une paix d'une nature qui l'homme naturel ne peut pas avoir.
Il ne peut pas connaître, il ne peut pas expérimenter.
C'est une paix spirituelle.
C'est une paix d'origine divine, c'est une paix des natures essentiellement connectées à notre relation avec Dieu.
Et c'est donc une paix qui a la capacité de surmonter tous les défis qui pourraient être portés contre cette paix.
La quête pour la paix est une quête universelle depuis tous les enregistrements humains de l'histoire humaine.
La quête pour la paix est l'une des quêtes les plus présentes, les plus évidentes.
Car cette paix, nous cherchons, quand on parle des menaces extérieures à l'humanité,
nos pages sont tachées par les sangs, par les guerres,
par l'animosité, par l'inimitié.
Mais pas qu'il y ait l'histoire des nations.
Ça commence avec nous-mêmes, les conflits qu'on a envers nous-mêmes,
l'incapacité de faire ce que nous savons être bon pour nous-mêmes,
de céder à nos passions et de vivre cette crise interne aussi,
avec la propre conscience, la coupabilité.
Manque de signification, des aspirations nobles,
mais une incapacité de vivre à la hauteur de ses propres aspirations.
Ça tâche donc ma relation avec moi-même.
Et ça a un impact, certainement, car je ne suis pas en équilibre ou en paix avec moi-même.
Ça réverbère envers les autres, même envers les personnes les plus chères.
Ce qui fait que ce soit doublement raisonnable la coupabilité qu'on porte.
Car nous avons la capacité, malgré les désirs de bien traiter ce qu'on aime le plus
et ce qui nous aime le plus,
ont fini pour manifester ces manques de paix internes
avec de l'animosité et violence envers eux-mêmes.
Donc dans nos relations avec nos semblables, même les plus proches,
nous expérimentons les manques de paix de manière écouante.
Et bien sûr que, comme les problèmes sont avec l'individu,
même si un milieu déjà très corrompu
peut servir comme un catalyseur,
l'environnement comme un catalyseur
pour favoriser un mauvais comportement,
ce n'est pas les milieux
qui sont à l'origine de la corruption de l'individu.
C'est l'inverse.
Si un jour le milieu a été corrompu,
l'environnement a été corrompu,
c'est à cause des individus qui étaient présents.
Donc les problèmes radicals, c'est l'homme,
c'est l'individu.
C'est un problème interne.
Et la quête de paix est donc quelque chose qui marque
notre vie personnelle,
l'histoire de l'humanité.
Et on a beau essayer en tant qu'être humain,
sans aide,
ou en rejetant plutôt l'aide
du diagnostic biblique,
on a beau essayer d'expliquer cette réalité.
Donc on a plein de théories
et on a non seulement essayé d'expliquer
les problèmes avec l'homme,
manque de paix,
dès l'explication
comme si on était
à cause de notre origine
animale,
la théorie de l'évolution,
qui fait qu'on accepte
ces manques de paix
à cause des manifestations
des restes,
des instants bestiales,
animaux qu'on avait avant.
C'est qu'ils cherchent
à enlever aussi
la responsabilisation
de nos actes.
C'est qu'ils cherchent
à justifier
nos mauvais comportements.
Pour d'autres,
c'est tout simplement
partie d'un processus.
Donc on ne veut pas parler
de manière positive
ou objective
par rapport à cette maladie
qui n'est pas traitée
par la Bible
comme une maladie.
C'est une conséquence
des nos mauvaises actions.
Et à partir du moment
où on commence
à développer
un nombre presque infini
des diagnostics
pour les troubles
du comportement
qu'on aime bien
embrasser très vite,
y compris l'Église
dans notre génération,
c'est vrai que
de justifier
mon manque de paix
à cause
du manque
de maîtrise de soi,
dans mes accès
de colère,
parfois un diagnostic
de bipolarité
ou de schizophrénie
peut sonner
comme un recours
plus efficace
au moins dans la surface
et dans l'immédiat
pour que je sois
un peu plus en paix
avec moi-même
et pour que les personnes
essayent d'être
un peu plus
en paix envers moi
en m'acceptant
avec ma maladie.
Ce n'est pas de cette manière
que la Bible présente
son diagnostic
et donc les traitements
qu'on essaie d'utiliser
ne sont pas efficaces
non plus
car
ils n'aident pas
effectivement
à régler les problèmes
car on est en train
de les diagnostiquer
d'une mauvaise façon
et en plus
ils ne font qu'agrandir
cette crise antérieure
des coupabilités
car la coupabilité
des êtres
qui ont été
créés par Dieu
pour habiter
dans les mondes
des dieux
ne sera jamais
effacée
de notre constitution
ça va toujours
revenir
et donc
nous sommes devenus
la génération
qui a cherché
à enlever
de notre vocabulaire
les conceptions
comme péché
erreur
ou transgression morale
on est la génération
du relativisme
on parle plutôt
en termes
des manques
des plus d'amour
d'affirmation
nous sommes la génération
de développement personnel
nous accepter
tel que nous sommes
et la génération
de la victimisation
c'est la manière
dont j'ai été élevé
c'est mon sang
italien
ou tout simplement
ces diagnostics
qu'on veut embrasser
nous sommes devenus
même
malgré
être
dans des pays
des premiers mondes
la France
est considérée
comme les plus grands
consommateurs
des psychotropes
et malheureusement
ces manques
de maîtrise
des soirs
qu'on devrait avoir
envers nous
ces manques
de responsabilisation
par rapport
à nos manquements
se prolongent
envers
nos enfants
il y a quelques années
n'étaient si facilement
n'étaient pas
si facilement
diagnostiqués
avec certains troubles
de comportement
et on s'est sorti
bien
on savait tout simplement
distinguer
un espectran
de tout simplement
différence
des tempéraments
un enfant
plus énergétique
naturellement
plus calme
et on savait
que c'était
plutôt à nous
les parents
de nous sacrifier
de donner plus
d'attention
de discipline
d'être plus
présent
et on a invité
cette même industrie
qui fait
les diagnostics
et qui nous propose
des médicaments
qui n'a pas les bases
bibliques
des diagnostics
pour nos enfants
pour nos vies
et on embrasse
car à la fin des comptes
ça peut être plus facile
d'accepter
de gérer
!
un moyen plus efficace
pour dans l'immédiat
de les calmer
sans mesurer
quelles seraient
les implications
à long terme
tout cela
n'est pas pour dire
que tous ces diagnostics
ne peuvent pas
s'appliquer
dans certains cas
mais il faut savoir
reconnaître
et faire une bonne
recherche
pour voir
de quelle manière
on a tellement
exagéré
ces choses
qui vont toujours
dans la direction
d'un traitement
insuffisant
un traitement
qui n'est pas radical
qui ne respecte pas
les diagnostics bibliques
et tout cela
pour vous exemplifier
cette tendance
que nous avons
et cette résistance
qu'on a
pour embrasser
la diagnostic biblique
les manques de paix
sont là pour tous
les raisons
pour ces manques de paix
sont plusieurs
elles vont toutes
traverser
la conception biblique
des transgressions
immoralité
et coupabilité
à leur racine
et tous les traitements
proposés
par la société
par les êtres humains
qui ne prennent pas
en compte
les diagnostics bibliques
n'arrivent jamais
à avoir
la même efficacité
qu'une vraie conversion
a eu lieu
dans la vie
de celui
qui s'est approché
des dieux
en assumant
ses fautes
ses coupabilités
et en ayant
toute l'assurance
que Christ
était suffisant
pour nous pardonner
parfaitement
et nous donner
la puissance
qui nous manque
car ce n'est pas
la connaissance
de ce qu'on devrait faire
qui nous manque
c'est la puissance
pour les faire
et ceux qui ont déjà
expérimenté la vraie conversion
savent expérimenter
l'efficacité
de la vie
et de la guérison
qu'on trouve en Christ
l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de parler
d'un élément
composant
du fruit
de l'esprit
c'est un élément
qui fait partie
de l'identité
et de la nature
même
du croyant
un croyant
sans paix
est une contradiction
un croyant
sans joie
est une contradiction
un croyant
qui expérimente
constamment
l'anxiété
et la crise
de panique
est une contradiction
il n'est pas en train
d'embrasser
les traitements
buliques
et peut-être
c'est pour ça
qu'on cherche
à embrasser
d'autres diagnostics
qui n'arrivent pas
à s'en sortir
mais il ne suffit pas
de vous porter
les mauvaises nouvelles
qui sont bonnes
pour qu'on redresse
et qu'on corrige
la chose à sa racine
mais c'est important aussi
de considérer
que ces fruits
sont une réalité
expérimentaire
et cultivable
au moins
un moment donné
dans la vie
de tous les vrais chrétiens
ils ont dû avoir
expérimenté
cette parfaite paix
cette paix radicale
et c'est une paix
qui reste
et restera
toujours accessible
à toutes les personnes
qui se sont vraiment
converties
et voilà pourquoi
l'espoir
que l'apôtre Paul
est en train d'apporter
envers les Galates
est un espoir
qui doit être apporté
et appliqué
à nous-mêmes
aujourd'hui
et comment
l'apôtre Paul
va traiter
les problèmes
des Galates
c'est cette communauté
qui avait commencé
très bien
cette communauté
qui avait commencé
au moment
de sa conversion
qui était sortie
d'une société
païenne
une société
qui était caractérisée
par les œuvres
de la chair
la promiscuité
les plaisirs
de la chair
l'idolâtrie
dans la pratique
religieuse
une conception
qui légitimait
leur promiscuité
et qui était aussi
marquée par
beaucoup d'animosité
beaucoup de guerre
et donc
cette petite communauté
en Galatie
s'est convertie
véritablement
à l'évangile
ils ont connu
les vrais dieux
sans avoir
un arrière-plan
juif
apôtre Paul
en faisant
ses voyages
missionnaires
a passé
par la Galatie
et a proclamé
Christ crucifié
dans la simplicité
de Jésus Christ
sans avoir
nécessairement
un arrière-plan
de l'Ancien Testament
en disant
tout simplement
par exemple
les fils des dieux
est venu au monde
les mondes
de ces créatures
car d'entre ces créatures
il n'y a aucun
être humain
qui arrive
à vivre
à la hauteur
de cette conscience
qu'ils ont
qui est
l'empreinte
et l'image
des dieux
dans l'être humain
cette moralité
dont les empreintes
on retrouve
dans chaque individu
dans tout l'univers
peu importe
qu'elles soient
leurs sources religieuses
ou leurs artifices
pour supprimer
cette conscience
et marcher
envers l'athéisme
donc les fils des dieux
des dieux créateurs
est venu
il a vécu
une vie parfaite
par amour
à ces créatures perdues
il a vécu
une vie parfaite
à leur place
et il est mort
à la croix
à leur place
il a vécu
une vie parfaite
d'amour
il a aimé
les personnes
et il a offert
cette réconciliation
par la foi
en lui
c'est à dire
je me suis
présenté
je me présente
à vous
comme
votre
représentant légal
devant
les tribunaux
des dieux
vous souffrez
tous
de cet esclavage
du manque
de paix
je suis venu
vous affranchir
la vraie liberté
vous savez
elle ne passe pas
par la suppression
des exigences morales
que vous avez
pour chercher
à vous convaincre
que la moralité
ne fait pas de sens
car vous êtes
originé
par une énergie
qui a explosé
qui ne pense pas
qui n'a pas de sentiments
qui n'a pas de moralité
la réalité
c'est que cette
moralité
qui persiste
dans votre conscience
pointe plutôt
envers
un dieu
sans
qui vous a créé
il vous a créé
pour lui-même
pour que vous trouviez
votre joie
votre plaisir
non dans la réjouissance
des bonnes choses
qu'il a créé
tout simplement
mais en lui
la source
de toutes ces choses
et comme vous savez
tout ce qui vous êtes
condamné
car vous n'arrivez pas
à avoir la paix
de réjouir
en paix
des bonnes choses
je suis venu
pour vivre cette vie
que vous n'arrivez pas
à vivre
et je suis allé
à la croix
pour souffrir
dans ma peau
c'est que vous
devriez souffrir
l'enfer
qui vous étiez
réservé
pour toute l'éternité
proportionnelle
à la gravité
de vos péchés
a été condensé
et il est retombé
sur moi
à la croix
et en ayant
satisfait
pleinement
ce que la justice
des dieux
exigeait en termes
des comportements
de votre part
je peux vous offrir
maintenant ma justice
et vous pardonner
car tous vos péchés
ont été expiés
dans ma souffrance
vous avez donc
l'opportunité
d'une nouvelle vie
avec un pardon parfait
une réconciliation
parfaite
accès à Dieu
restauration
de votre comportement
inconformité
avec votre propre
conscience
inconformité
à l'image
de Dieu
à la vie
d'amour
que Dieu vit
et la question
c'est
voulez-vous
embrasser
Christ
comme votre justice
embrasser
Christ
comme votre
substitut
légal
l'apôtre Paul
a prêché
cet évangile
dans cette simplicité
et les Galaxies
se sont converties
sans aucun arrière-plan
payant
les Saint-Esprit
avaient eu
ils ont expérimenté
cette paix
et l'apôtre Paul
a dit
vous avez commencé
très bien la course
le problème
c'est qu'il reste
de cette tendance
à chercher plutôt
à conquérir
notre paix
par nos efforts
être à la hauteur
de la conscience
ou être à la hauteur
de la loi de Dieu
c'est reste
des tentations
que nous devons
faire taire
et nous rappeler
à chaque fois
Christ a tout payé
Dieu est pour moi
il me traite
comme un enfant
cette expérience
a été tordue
au sein
de l'église
des Galates
car les judaïsants
sont arrivés
c'était des hommes
qui disaient croire
que Christ
était des vrais sauveurs
mais qu'à cause
de l'influence
de la mauvaise
interprétation juive
de leur perspective
de sauveur
des messianiques
les judaïsants
ils ont commencé
à en serrer
certaines pensées
qui allaient
un peu dans cette direction
vous êtes vraiment converti
car vous avez cru
à Christ
mais maintenant
vous devez vous adapter
à cette manière
qui Dieu a toujours développé
avec nous
les juifs
car vous savez
que les saluts
viennent des juifs
les seins Jésus
il était juif
et au lieu
de considérer
tout ce qui
pointait envers Christ
comme des ombres
envers Christ
et Christ
infiniment supérieur
ils ont cherché
à adapter
les convertis païens
à la culture juive
aujourd'hui
par exemple
imaginons la folie
si jamais
on aurait l'idée
de nous dire
bon on peut peut-être
commencer à mettre
des bagnées d'Israël
ici
ou faire
une espèce
de reproduction
de l'arche
de l'alliance
il y avait
beaucoup de préoccupations
avec la manière
dont ils étaient
en train de se vêtir
donc peut-être
qu'on pourrait commencer
tous à nous habiller
de la même manière
et établir
quelques règles
il faut que la joute
va jusqu'au là
il faut qu'on ne touche
pas aux cheveux
et comme il y avait
beaucoup d'instruments
et des cérémonies
qui cherchaient
à porter un enseignement
plus profond
du baison du Christ
la sensation
c'est que
beaucoup de choses
envers Dieu
s'est passées
de manière automatique
donc peut-être
que la sainte sainte
soit une manière
de vous pardonner
directement
renouveler votre pardon
ou le sacrifice
du Christ
comme l'a fait
l'église catholique
qui est très judaïsante
peut-être
que votre fidélité
dans votre assiduité
dans votre performance
si on fait
par exemple
des campagnes
ou des sacrifices
on peut plutôt
convaincre Dieu
de nous bénir
et de petit à petit
l'image de Dieu
pour nous
n'est plus cette image
d'un Dieu père
qui nous adopte
en tant qu'enfant
en Jésus
un Jésus parfait
qui assure absolument
notre position d'enfant
mais nous revenons
en rapport envers Dieu
qui est un rapport légaliste
qui dépend
de notre performance
de notre manière
de conquérir la paix
et qui développe
un rapport
envers la loi des dieux
comme si elle était
la personnalisation
d'un Dieu lui-même
contre nous
avec un doigt pointé
en cherchant
à nous trouver
en faute
pour enlever
ces bénédictions
et même les saluent
selon certaines conceptions
judaïsantes
légalistes
encore dans nos jours
si notre relation
envers Dieu
est néovrotique
on a annulé
la grâce de Dieu
selon l'apôtre Paul
en Galacte
Christ est mort
en vent
si jamais il y a eu
la moindre possibilité
que vous pouviez
vous sauver vous-même
par vos performances
par votre comportement
ça serait une folie
de la part de Dieu
d'envoyer son fils
aimé
pour mourir
à la croix
si la moindre possibilité
de salut
était possible
pour l'être humain
Dieu ne serait pas folle
d'envoyer son fils
pour mourir
et donc
la bataille
de l'apôtre Paul
ici c'est
vous aviez goûté
la parfaite paix
au moment
de votre conversion
et maintenant
vous êtes en train
de revenir en arrière
relation néovrotique
avec Dieu
contre nous
qu'est-ce que l'apôtre Paul
il fait
il ne veut pas
donner une liste
de ceux qui
à partir de là
pour restaurer leur paix
les Galates
doivent faire ceci
ou ils doivent
faire cela
l'apôtre Paul
il fait un rappel
de ce qu'ils sont
et ça c'est l'un
des plus grands problèmes
avec les chrétiens
crise d'identité
ne pas connaître
ces phénomènes
que Dieu a opéré en nous
la gloire
de l'évangile
décrit
dans le Nouveau Testament
c'est la gloire
de l'autoconnaissance
dans notre nouvelle nature
et la connaissance
de ces phénomènes
surnaturels
qui a été
la régénération
qui a dû opérer
au moment de notre conversion
l'apôtre Paul
il est en train de parler
de quelque chose
qui devrait
avoir été
expérimenté
de manière radicale
chez nous
quand il parle
du fruit de l'esprit
et quelque chose
qui devrait être
organique
fruit
naturel
pas des choses
qu'on pourrait
s'efforcer
pour produire
par nos propres forces
il est en train
de décrire
quelle nature
d'arbre
nous sommes
vous êtes avec moi
et c'est étonnant
car même
que l'emphase
ne soit pas mise
dans ce qu'on devrait faire
même qu'on n'ait pas
besoin des menaces
on est davantage
motivé
à nous sanctifier
d'une manière
beaucoup plus efficace
par cette manière
la preuve
que cette expérience
de conversion
a été réelle
dans nos vies
c'est qu'un vrai chrétien
n'utilise jamais
la grâce de Dieu
comme un prétexte
pour rester dans les péchés
n'utilisez pas
de cette liberté
comme un prétexte
pour rester dans les péchés
au contraire
en ayant été tellement
assuré
du pardon des dieux
et de la présence
du Saint-Esprit
dans vos vies
pour vous conduire
à la sanctification
produisez
vous êtes avec moi
les Saint-Esprit
habitent en vous
résistez à la chair
ce sont les restes
cette chair
que l'apôtre Paul dit
dans ses passages
je vous rappelle
qui a été déjà crucifiée
vous êtes déjà crucifié
avec Christ
vos passions
c'est-à-dire en coup mortel
les restes
de la chair
sont
infiniment inférieurs
dans ses forces
par rapport
à notre nouvelle nature
couplée
à la présence
du Saint-Esprit
tout-puissant en nous
et c'est
dommage
et triste
que plusieurs églises
donnent beaucoup plus
de forces
à la chair
qui mettent
l'emphase biblique
sur les forces
qu'on a en Christ
voilà pourquoi
les appels
bibliques
c'est
assumer
votre identité
marcher
en cohérence
ou conformité
avec cette puissance
chez vous
mais malheureusement
il y a beaucoup
d'églises
qui vont présenter
la notion
de sanctification
comme si les péchés
étaient beaucoup plus forts
et des chrétiens
qui restent toujours
dans l'immaturité
et qui se victimisent
trop
au lieu de saisir
cette description
et donc
marcher
dans l'esprit
et vous
ne satisférez
jamais
les désirs
de la chair
pour comprendre
cette paix
spécifiquement
cet aspect
de ses fruits
on a fait
une déclaration
principale
la vérité
centrale
pour nous
c'est que
cette paix
est un élément
essentiel
de la liberté
chrétienne
et elle doit
être constamment
expérimentée
elle doit être
évidemment visible
elle doit donc
être préservée
et cultivée
dans la vie
des tout véritables
enfants des dieux
car elle est
un fruit
qui marque
et caractérise
un enfant des dieux
un héritier
des dieux
voilà pourquoi
lorsque Paul décrit
notre vie
avant la conversion
c'est
les œuvres
de la chair
si vous galates
aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train
de vous
comporter
avec de la division
de l'opposition
vous vous mordez
et vous vous dévorez
et notamment
à cause du fait
que ces hommes
qui sont pénétrés
dans cette église
vous ont
contaminés
avec une idée
d'un Dieu
contre vous
comme si vous
devriez
revenir
à maintenir
une base
de relation
avec Dieu
basée sur
votre performance
non par rapport
à ce que Christ
a déjà fait
mais par rapport
à ce que vous
devriez faire
si ça
c'est la base
de votre relation
avec Dieu
vous avez
perdu
votre liberté
la liberté
chrétienne
elle est marquée
pour un désir
et une puissance
pour marcher
naturellement
dans la direction
du plan
accomplissement
du but
de notre existence
vivre la vie
que Dieu vit
en commun
parfait
avec Dieu
en paix
et donc
c'est l'opposé
des œuvres
de la chair
envers lesquelles
on était esclave
et c'est donc
la paix
qui marque
et qui est une évidence
de la vraie
naissance spirituelle
la question pour nous
c'est comment préserver
cultiver
et expérimenter
cette paix
dans notre vie
quotidienne
on va considérer
trois réponses
la première
c'est celle
qu'on a vu
déjà
la semaine dernière
et c'est tout simplement
comprendre
la nature
de cette paix
ok
donc on est en train
de parler
d'un arbre
qui a été
originé
par Dieu
c'est pas une paix
qui puisse expérimenter
les autres
c'est pas comme on a
déjà dit
c'est de quelle nature
cette paix
c'est pas par exemple
une attitude
pacifiste
les procureurs
de la paix
ou les pacificateurs
selon la Bible
ce sont ceux
qui vont chercher
la vraie
réconciliation
ils vont vouloir
promouvoir
la vraie réconciliation
tant que les personnes
ne soient pas
véritablement réconciliées
tout simplement
d'éviter les disputes
n'est pas forcément
cette paix
elle est enracinée
dans une réconciliation
profonde
avec Dieu
et qui promeut
des réconciliations
profondes
entre les êtres
humains
d'accord
et donc c'est pas
tout simplement
une personne
qui est née
avec un tempérament
plus calme
comme certains animaux
par rapport à d'autres
cette paix
est d'une autre nature
et donc c'est pas
la capacité
d'éviter les problèmes
et ni même
la capacité
de faire semblant
qu'on n'ait pas
si touché
par ces événements
extérieurs
par la manière
dont les personnes
nous provoquent
mais c'est
une paix
qui sera
évidente
à l'extérieur
un fruit
visible
qui ne peut
pas exister
s'il n'a pas
une racine
invisible
une sève
qui coule
de son esprit
une racine
qui est
l'évangile
de Jésus Christ
on se rappelle
que la description
de ces fruits
sont symétriques
c'est un fruit
qui est symétrique
car toutes ces vertus
apparaissent
en même temps
car elles sont
interconnectées
interdépendantes
toutes enracinées
en Christ
toutes enveloppées
et connectées
par l'amour
qui est
les premiers évoqués
l'élément
mais c'est celui
qui soutient
tous les éléments
et qui à la fin
des comptes
c'est rien
de plus
que la description
du caractère
du Christ lui-même
des dieux lui-même
c'est Christ
vu en nous
expérimenté
en nous
et donc
c'est
cette nature
de paix
donc
quelle est
la nature
de paix
selon la compréhension
des Galates
la paix
dans la conception
occidentale
était plutôt
la sérénité
d'esprit
ou de pensée
ou plutôt
la tranquillité
cela avait
à voir
plus
à la notion
d'une espèce
de conformisme
d'accepter
les choses
sans
trop réagir
avec manque
de paix
soit
chercher
à éviter
les douleurs
ou les troubles
par des efforts
personnels
une espèce
d'autosuffisance
une indépendance
peut-être
une prospérité
financière
pour pouvoir
éviter
les principales
causes des troubles
que je peux expérimenter
dans cette vie
c'était la mentalité
grecque
occidentale
parfois
donc
avec une espèce
d'autodiscipline
infligée
austérité
s'habituer
à souffrir
sans souffrir
trop
à l'intérieur
soit
chercher
à profiter
les meilleures
choses
de cette vie
en évitant
les maximum
possible
les douleurs
et les troubles
c'était
différent
car très pragmatique
de la conception
juive
des paix
la conception
biblique
des paix
donc quels
sont les termes
qui viennent à l'esprit
quand on pense
à la paix
selon la bible
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui peut dire
chalon
donc la conception
biblique des chalons
elle est profondément
enracinée
à la conception
de la création
originale
déjà c'est un terme
très relationnel
car
les sommets
du chalon
quelque part
c'est cette connexion
avec Dieu
et c'est ce but
d'existence
si élevé
qui est être
image de Dieu
cette image
de Dieu
qui est dans sa paix
c'est-à-dire
dans son équilibre
car littéralement
ça veut dire
complétude
intégrité
ce n'est pas une espèce
de fragmentation
de l'être
en cherchant
ici
ou là-bas
un petit peu
de plaisir
de paix
mais c'est
cette intégrité
ces fruits
interconnectés
ces chalons
ils touchent donc
cette relation
essentielle
envers Dieu
qui est la base
et le fondement
de notre raison d'être
et donc
la relation
avec moi-même
en paix
avec ma mission
ma signification
c'est qui me donne
la base
pour être
en paix
envers l'autre
intègre
inséparable
je ne peux
qu'être
paisible
visiblement
envers l'autre
si je n'ai pas
la paix
envers moi-même
cette paix
qui est fondée
dans ma relation
avec Dieu
et donc
la paix
avec l'environnement
aussi
les rapports
envers ce monde
car
quelles sont
les principales sources
des manques
de paix
dans nos expériences
de vie
si on essaie
d'être très solitaire
on est devant
la fragilité
de notre corps
de notre vie
devant les menaces
de ce monde
l'interaction
avec cet univers
n'est pas très
sécurisante
mais il y a
des choses
qui nous gênent
encore plus
et ce sont
les manques
de paix
dans les relations
et le manque
de paix
ou le manque
envers moi-même
et notamment
la racine
fondamentale
manque de paix
avec Dieu
voilà pourquoi
la réconciliation
avec Dieu
est le seul
moyen
véritable
pour que
cette paix
des natures
spirituelles
est pleine
cette complitude
ait lieu
quand on revient
à la conception
du chalon
biblique
c'est une paix
relationnelle
qui a son fondement
un Dieu
et qui s'y exprime
dans toutes les airs
et dans toutes les relations
de la vie
voilà pourquoi
cette notion
de prospérité
de paix
était là
et la semaine
était structurée
d'une manière
très intéressante
car la paix
était scellée
par les sabbats
qui portent
cette notion
de paix
les sabbats
ils étaient
les sots
ou les sommets
de la paix
car
en ayant
accompli
les buts
de son existence
pendant la semaine
parfaite
travailler
les six jours
produire
représenter Dieu
imiter Dieu
trouver sa signification
dans l'interaction
avec le monde
l'univers
dans l'interaction
maritale
familiale
et
cette sensation
d'avoir
la satisfaction
d'avoir accompli
l'image de Dieu
avoir produit
les biens
vivre
pour la gloire
des dieux
on arrivait
donc les sabbats
pour cette
prestation
des comptes
qui en réalité
c'était un repos
dans quel sens
c'était
pouvoir
nous présenter
devant Dieu
avec notre conscience
pleinement satisfaite
en parfaite
paix
et réjouir
le sourire
des dieux
qui nous dirait
je vois
ma vie
en toi
je vois
que tu produis
les biens
comme moi
j'ai produit
les biens
je considère
les plaisirs
que tu as
en exerçant
ton rôle
en tant qu'homme
dans cette relation
et ton rôle
en tant que femme
dans cette relation
et nous pourrions
aller
envers les sabbats
à l'origine
aller dans
en parfaite paix
et réjouir
du sommet
de ces chalons
qui étaient
la prospérité
de notre intimité
avec Dieu
et c'est clair
qu'après la chute
on a perdu
toutes ces capacités
la relation
avec Dieu coupée
divisée
de nous-mêmes
dans cette guerre
des sexes
à l'intérieur
du mariage
de la famille
et
cette hostilité
de la création
envers nous
Dieu va rénouveler
cet espoir
didactiquement
par l'histoire
d'Israël
la terre promise
Canaan
des livros
de l'Égypte
etc.
et renouvellement
des dix commandements
ou la consommation
externe
des dix commandements
en gardant
un signe
dans les décalogues
les sabbats
l'espoir
de la paix restaurée
mais qui était
très mélancolique
c'était
les jours
les plus fatigants
pour Israël
les jours
des sacrifices
des restrictions
les jours
qui rappelaient
les besoins
absolus
pour que votre paix
soit réelle
et que les paradis
soient restaurés
les messieurs
viennent
l'agneau parfait
et voilà pourquoi
l'image de la Pâque
était très importante
en termes d'expiation
car par les animaux
Dieu ne faisait
qu'apaiser
sa colère
mais jamais
pourvu
la paix
effective
absolue
avant que Christ
ne vienne
c'était une paix
anticipée
basée sur les
Christ
qui viendrait
l'agneau des dieux
et donc on doit
comprendre la nature
organique
de cette paix
chrétienne
qui est
fondée
dans cette
création
à l'image
de Dieu
en relation
avec Dieu
pour fonctionner
comme Dieu
dans toutes nos
interactions
personnelles
interpersonnelles
et avec les mondes
et nous pouvons
donc comprendre
que cette paix
parfaite
ne peut qu'être
restaurée
si
la réconciliation
avec Dieu
a lieu
et donc le deuxième
point qu'on considère
c'est que nous devons
attention
considérer
la nature
de l'arbre
quelle est la nature
des paix
je viens de vous présenter
une paix spirituelle
la deuxième question
c'est
cette paix
elle découle
de cette union
avec la racine
vous êtes avec moi
qui est la racine
de cette paix
pour nous
qui est le prince
de la paix
le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
et donc
si nous voulons
préserver
cette paix
si nous avons
déjà un jour
expérimenté
cette paix
si nous voulons
un jour
expérimenter
cette paix
les débuts
attention
les fruits
de l'esprit
attention
il est quelque part
il n'est pas
forcément
immédiatement
ce qu'on apprend
comme la
la paix
avec Dieu
c'est la paix
des dieux
ok
dans quel sens
les fruits
c'est une conséquence
de la vraie conversion
c'est une évidence
mais il est
de la même nature
et sans que la vraie conversion
soit marquée
par ces mêmes éléments
c'est impossible
que ces fruits
soient produits
l'expérience
des conversions
est décrite
dans la Bible
comme l'expérience
de la réconciliation
avec Dieu
c'est la paix
des dieux
c'est Christ
qui nous a
fait la paix
avec Dieu
et c'est la seule raison
pour que
pour plus
qu'un être humain
soit prospère
dans sa vie
et en bonne santé
le goût
de la meilleure nourriture
est toujours amer
c'est difficile
à dormir
sans l'aide
des médicaments
des distractions
car pour plus
qui prospère
un être humain
dans ce monde
s'il n'a pas
la paix avec Dieu
il est constamment
en train de souffrir
les assauts
de sa propre conscience
et donc
nous devons
surtout préserver
cette connexion
constante
cette conscience
avec la racine
de notre paix
car les fruits
aura les mêmes goûts
les fruits
aura la même saine
le Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
est appelé
l'Esprit du Christ
si c'est lui
qui nous donne
ce qu'il faut
pour qu'on produise
ces fruits
c'est car
il est
ou il a
pour ministère principal
quel est le ministère
principal du Saint-Esprit
produire
l'union
avec Christ
par la foi
Christ a fait
la paix
avec Dieu
car il a vécu
une vie parfaite
à ma place
il est mort
à la croix
à ma place
et donc
le Saint-Esprit
me donne
toute la conviction
que je suis unie
à Christ
dans sa vie
je suis unie
à Christ
dans sa mort
et donc
je suis unie
à l'identité
du Christ
pour être sûr
que Dieu a fait
de moi
un enfant
parfaitement
acceptable
ce qui a été
vrai à propos
de moi
a été pris par Dieu
comme vrai à propos
du Christ
c'est à dire
Dieu n'a pas pu
épargner
une seule goutte
de sa colère
qui a été déversée
en Christ
car Christ a
véritablement
pris ma place
mon abomination
mes transgressions
et aujourd'hui
je peux vivre
devant Dieu
non seulement
me présenter
devant Dieu
au moment de ma conversion
mais vivre
pour toujours
devant Dieu
avec la pleine assurance
qu'il va me traiter
comme son enfant
bien-aimé
c'est qu'il a dit
à Christ
au moment de son baptême
et à la montagne
de la transfiguration
voici mon fils
bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
est vrai pour nous
car nous sommes en lui
nous sommes greffés
à cette vigne
et douter
du fait
que Dieu
serait déterminé
à m'étraiter
comme Christ
c'est de douter
si Christ a
véritablement
pris ma place
ou si Christ
était véritablement
si digne
et c'est
un des péchés
les plus graves
moralement
c'est un mépris
de la croix
du Christ
de la souffrance
qui Dieu a traversé
pour envoyer Christ
de douter
de l'amour
de Dieu
et des bonnes intentions
dans notre vie
l'anxiété
les manques
de paix
la syndrome
du panique
c'est de dire
malgré
cette preuve
historique
cabale
glorieuse
d'amour
pour moi
car quand j'étais
encore ennemi
Christ est mort
pour moi
à la croix
il a annulé
les cris
des dettes
contre moi
en les clouant
dans son fils
à la croix
et flirter
avec
anxiété
c'est d'obstacuriser
complètement
la plus grande
preuve d'amour
la plus explicite
les pages
de l'histoire
sont divisées
entre avant Christ
et après Christ
c'est la preuve
d'amour
la plus explicite
la plus puissante
la plus forte
c'est lui
qui n'a pas épargné
son propre fils
mais qui l'a
livré pour vous
est-ce qu'il ne va pas
vous donner avec lui
toutes les choses
c'est tout simplement
irrationnel
selon les informations
chrétiennes
mais le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
connait notre structure
il sait
qu'il nous sent
de la poussière
il est encore
compatissant
et voilà pourquoi
il donne
ses sermons
ou cette partie
du serment
sur la montagne
quand il parle
contre l'anxiété
en nous donnant
un ordre
ne soyez pas inquiet
mais il nous donne
aussi un arsenal
voici pourquoi
vous ne devriez pas
être inquiet
et donc
le plus important
pour nous
c'est de préserver
constamment
nos yeux fixés
sur les princes
de la paix
à la racine
de cet arbre
et de comprendre
pourquoi Christ
est décrit
dans la Bible
comme les princes
de la paix
il est décrit
comme les princes
de la paix
car il réjouit
pleinement
du chalon parfait
il est
la deuxième personne
de la saint trinité
en communion parfaite
en félicité
pleine
il est celui
donc le caractère
ne peut pas être
ébranlé
il est la source
quelque part
de cette image
des dieux
qui nous sommes
selon
sa forme
son modèle
il est en parfaite paix
car il n'y a jamais
un doute
par rapport
aux bonnes intentions
des dieux
qui puissent croiser
sa tête
si possible
n'est pas traversé
cette croix
toutefois
qui est à volonté
soit faite
c'est un Christ
qui est malgré
une sensibilité
infiniment
plus grande
que la nôtre
pour les crises
qu'on traverse
il a réussi à vivre
c'est quoi cette paix
cette paix
c'est
en ayant Christ
pour bouclier
et fondément
assuré
pour une paix
parfaite
future
nous pouvons déjà
expérimenter
une paix
présente
qui est lorsqu'il est
confronté
par n'importe
quelle menace
dans cette vie
aucune menace
n'a la capacité
de l'embreler
la paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
toute circonstance
quand on est en train
de
être confronté
par des catastrophes
des guerres
ou même
les crises
les plus bêtes
pourquoi
pendant les cultes
les pasteurs
versent les cafés
sur mes chaussures
blancs
c'est facile
devant les pasteurs
la communauté
de ne pas réagir
en colère
mais si c'était
mon enfant à la maison
avant d'arriver ici
que ce soit
les motivations
les plus bêtes
ou les questions
les plus élevées
pourquoi
tous ne sont pas sauvés
les péchés
ont été permis
!
Pourquoi
les catastrophes
les guerres
si Christ
était beaucoup plus sensible
et vous ne pouvez
qu'avoir ces questions
car vous avez
une moralité
qui est Dieu
insérée chez vous
notre sens de justice
est comme
les vêtements
intimes
sales
comme la Bible
nous l'a dit
mais la réalité
c'est que si
ces questions
nous font paralyser
arrêter de vivre
!
si Christ a réussi
à vivre
la folie
de ces raisonnements
c'est de nous arrêter
et nous dire
mais comment
je pourrais oser
m'émettre
la place de Dieu
si j'étais à sa place
je ferais différemment
je ferais mieux
si c'est clair
dans sa parole
moi je n'ai pas
de réponse
pour toutes ces questions
je ne veux pas
me retarder
dans ces questions
Dieu veut
qu'on vit
une vie décompliquée
en faisant confiance
à sa souveraineté
paternelle
il nous a déjà
assuré
je suis les Pères Célestes
je gouverne
chaque attaque
il n'y a aucune chose
qui échappe
à mon contrôle
tout concourt au bien
de ceux qui aiment
à Dieu
donc c'est à toi
tout simplement
de plier vos genoux
de marcher
de faire quelque chose
de produire
de vous scientifier
de vivre
c'est de confronter
il ne faut pas
papoter avec Satan
c'est de confronter
ses doutes
avec des résolutions
avec des déterminations
mais si jamais
ceci se passe
si jamais
cela se passe
les démons
porteront ses soins
à chaque jour
suffit sa peine
chercher d'abord
mon rohème
et ma justice
Dieu nous a donné
déjà
un encadrement
parfait des Pères
un fondement
indoubitable
des Pères
et il nous pousse
vers l'avant
car
en ayant
scellé cette Père
d'une fois pour toutes
dans les passés
quand on contemple la croix
en expérimentant
la réalité de cette Père
par son esprit
dont les ministères
et de dire constamment
à nos esprits
vous êtes les enfants
des dieux
on n'a pas reçu
un esprit d'esclavage
pour avoir la peur
comme si Dieu était
encore contre nous
c'est un esprit
d'adoption
par lesquels
on crie
Abba Père
je m'élève
malgré toutes les difficultés
mon rédempteur vit
règne
ces choses
qui peuvent sonner
comme mal pour moi
sont
pour mon bien
pour progresser
son royaume
et on y va
dans l'aventure
une paix expérimentée
dans les présents
et une certitude
absolue
qui nous rend capable
même de faire face
à la mort
où est l'aguillon
de la mort
c'est qui nous attend
après cette vie
qui peut être marquée
par quelques souffrances
pour avancer
les royaumes
pour perfectionner
ma vie
pour faire que moi
je sois plus semblable
à Christ
je peux progresser
constamment
avec cette sensation
que Dieu regarde
ma vie
et il se retrouve
en moi
restauration de son image
il n'y a aucun plaisir
plus grand
et encore
j'essaie
que j'arriverai
à ces repos
dont Fabien nous parle
qui restent encore
pour les enfants des dieux
les chalons parfaits
les sabbats parfaits
donc Christ nous a présenté
comme celui
qui dans son identité
est le prince de paix
il est l'héros
de la paix
si vous voulez
il est celui
qui est venu
avec la puissance divine
pour faire ce qu'il fallait faire
afin de nous assurer
qu'il serait efficace
dans cette oeuvre
de réconciliation
et non seulement
réconciliation
pour nous pardonner
mais réconciliation
dans le sens
chalon
qui restaure
son image en nous
notre relation
avec nous
avec les autres
avec les mondes
et nous devenons
les agents de chalons
dans cette vie
avec l'assurance
que les chalons parfaits
nous attendent
donc dimanche
pour nous
est tellement important
c'est l'anticipation
de ces chalons parfaits
et c'est l'intensification
de ces chalons présents
dont connexion
à la racine
et nous devons aussi
considérer
qu'il est Christ
qui est notre chalon parfait
notre sabbat parfait
nous a donné son esprit
et là
on est plus
directement connecté
à la connaissance
du fruit
le dernier point
c'est nous efforcer
intentionnellement
pour manifester
l'efficacité
du fruit de l'esprit
par des efforts
intentionnels
ou par une coopération
intentionnelle
avec le Saint-Esprit
c'est-à-dire
connecté à Christ
avec nos yeux
focalisés sur Christ
un expériment
en la paix
avec Christ
nous devons faire
un petit effort
les privilèges
que le Saint-Esprit
nous donne
de coopérer
avec le Saint-Esprit
avec notre sanctification
il opère
les vouloirs
et les faire
mais nous avons
des exhortations
aussi
qui font
qu'on doit participer
quelque part
à produire
cet effort
qu'il ne peut pas avoir
nous-mêmes
par mérite
mais en étant
une arbre
une branche
greffée
à Christ
la sève
de l'esprit
passe par nous
produit
inévitablement
les fruits
et nous avons
les privilèges
de quelque part
participer
dans la proportion
dont ces fruits
sont remportés
d'un côté
il faut confronter
dans les passages
et dans les contextes
cette paix
avec les œuvres
de la chair
c'est-à-dire
à chaque fois
qu'une tentation
pour qu'on produise
un mauvais fruit
ou que les herbes
commencent à pousser
les mauvaises herbes
on doit réagir
et chaque élément
du fruit de l'esprit
est capable
de détruire
toutes les œuvres
de la chair
qui marquaient
notre vie
dans le passé
lorsque ces tentations
apparaissent
je dois prendre
cette paix
et confronter
et cet exercice
il est très important
car il est très pratique
donc devant
l'impudicité
l'impureté
la dissolution
l'immoralité sexuelle
de manière générale
la paix
qui nous est présentée
en Christ
c'est ces chalons
parfaits
c'est cette
satisfaction
parfaite
en Dieu
l'élément
le plus puissant
pour protéger
un homme
contre
ces types
de chutes
c'est de savoir
que sa relation
avec Dieu
sa paix
son chalon
sera profondément
abîmée
et voilà pourquoi
Satan va maximiser
sur ces choses
les premiers
à nous encourager
au péché
et une fois
qu'on chute
c'est les premiers
!
à nous accuser
mais si je sais
que cette paix
qui a été acquise
par un prix
si haut
préserve
cette relation
si belle
avec une capacité
réelle
de réjouir
de cette paix
je suis satisfait
je suis plus satisfait
dans ma relation
intime avec Dieu
qu'aucune femme
ne pourrait
me présenter
comme tentation
aujourd'hui
l'arme la plus efficace
c'est de réjouir
du chalon
de l'intimité
de la relation
avec Christ
l'idolâtrie
ou la magie
donc c'est clair
que si l'échalon
à l'origine
et l'échalon
restauré par Christ
a dans son sommet
la réjouissance
et la relation
avec Dieu
être approuvé
par Dieu
recevoir
ses compliments
de la part de Dieu
mon fils bien-aimé
avec lui
j'ai mis
toute mon affection
aucune
aucune autre
idole
ne peut remplacer
Dieu dans ma vie
aucune personne
aucune chose
aucun argent
aucune tentation
ne peut être comparable
au plaisir
que j'ai dans la réjouissance
des dieux
et la magie
on a déjà vu
pharmaquelles
et je reviens
à l'introduction
du culte
les pharmaquelles
ce sont
des propositions
pour enlever
tout ce
qui enlève
notre paix
dans le quotidien
selon les raisonnements
humains
qui peut avoir
une mesure
des bases scientifiques
mais selon
les textes
dans l'origine
il y avait aussi
pas mal
d'ésotérismes
pas forcément
médicalement prouvé
que cela peut marcher
pas forcément
scientifiquement prouvé
que ces diagnostics
soient
véritablement précis
que cela soit
la cause
du problème
c'est de se donner
et se laisser
traiter
par toutes
les voies
et mesures
qui ne sont pas
issues
de la parole
de Dieu
qui ne sont pas
permises
par la parole
de Dieu
qui ne font pas
d'essence
selon la parole
de Dieu
quelle est
la racine
du problème
des paix
pour nous
on peut penser
que ce sont
toutes ces autres raisons
et essayer
de prendre
tous ces médicaments
et dans la plupart
du temps
on est en train
plutôt
de distraire
les raisonnements
au lieu
de raisonner
avec la Bible
ouverte
et trouver
la seule source
des paix
qui peut
véritablement
changer
les circonstances
inimité
querelle
jalousie
animosité
dispute
c'est l'opposé
les plus immédiat
de la paix
révélé
dans nos relations
dans nos interactions
sauf que
si quelqu'un
a véritablement
été réconcilié
avec Dieu
il n'est pas
facilement blessé
très intéressé
à l'autopromotion
à être correct
dans toutes les discussions
il a une vie
beaucoup plus fondée
sur ses
pardons divins
envers
mon animosité
envers Dieu
et mon objectif
dans ses interactions
même sous attaque
c'est de produire
avec patience
la paix
et la réconciliation
une personne
qui est toujours
en colère
est une personne
qui n'a pas
expérimenté
cette paix
division
et secte
qui sonnent
comme zèle
pour la vérité
des séparations
non nécessaires
au sein
du peuple
et Dieu
c'est clair
que nous pouvons
avoir des maturités
des niveaux
de maturité
différents
et c'est clair
que l'apôtre Paul
en Galate
même
nous parle
qu'il y a
un vrai évangile
et un faux évangile
et donc là
il faut véritablement
avoir un secte
donc la scission
avec l'église catholique
au 16e siècle
c'était légitime
car
les cœurs
de l'évangile
étaient corrompus
l'évangile
de la théologie
de la prospérité
aujourd'hui
il faut avoir
une scission
car ça ne représente
pas l'évangile
biblique
c'est anathème
le triomphalisme
gospel
le gospel
du développement
personnel
par contre
il y a un nombre
assez généreux
des points
de divergence
légitime
au long de l'histoire
de l'église
qui peuvent
soit représenter
plus ou moins
de maturité
de compréhension
biblique
mais qui ne peuvent
pas justifier
la séparation
et les manques
de paix
les manques
de certitude
qui nous sommes tous
frères et sœurs
même si on n'a pas
les mêmes niveaux
de santé spirituelle
peut conduire
certains
à subir
à cette exhortation
que Christ a dit
à Jean
ne fait pas
un de ses petits
trébouchés
mieux
c'est d'attacher
une pierre au cou
et se lancer
dans la rivière
savoir
distinguer
c'est donc
notre paix
avec Dieu
dépend
les vrais évangiles
et la générosité
envers
quelques divergences
donc l'envie
qui c'est plutôt
la potréfaction
de l'âme
l'envie
qui est quelque part
une mise en question
de la paternité
des dieux
envers
tous ses enfants
et une mise en question
de la souveraineté
des dieux
de la sagesse
dans ses plans
c'est quoi l'envie
à la fin des comptes
c'est de ne pas
être content
avec les lots
qui Dieu a décidé
pour moi
aujourd'hui
c'est de douter
s'il est vraiment
un père
un père juste
c'est de se démarrer
trop dans des questions
pourquoi les empires
prospèrent
pourquoi je suis
si longtemps
en train d'attendre
ma bénédiction
et ses frères
qui viennent
de se convertir
reçoivent
plutôt que moi
envie
manque de chalons
manque de confiance
dans la paternité
des dieux
l'ivronnierie
et les excès tables
en général
ce sont les manières
les plus bestiales
d'étordre
la bonne relation
avec les bonnes choses
qu'il doit créer
manque d'équilibre
manque de complitude
des chalons
et parfois
idolâtrie
attendre
de ses plaisirs
combler
envie
des mentes épais
des joies
des satisfactions
élever
d'autres puissances
ce qui devrait
tout simplement
accomplir son rôle
dans un monde
qui a été créé
par Dieu
avec des bonnes choses
pour notre fonctionnement
et donc par là
on parle
de la maîtrise
des soirs
et les plus
âgés
nous sommes
le plus nous voyons
l'importance
de la maîtrise
et donc il faut
qu'on soit intentionnel
à chaque fois
qu'on est tenté
par ces choses
on va se dire
non je suis satisfait
j'ai déjà pris assez
j'ai pas besoin
d'agir de cette manière
je reviens
à la racine
à la paix
et je suis aussi fortifié
par l'intentionnalité
que les fruits portés
soient boostés
et qu'ils puissent aussi
booster
les autres éléments
de ces fruits
on commence par
l'amour
des dieux
révélé en Christ
qui est le fondement
ultime de la paix
l'amour
c'est cet encadrement
dont je vous ai parlé
Dieu a tellement aimé
le monde
qu'il a donné son fils
pour notre réconciliation
et donc
si j'expérimente
véritablement
l'amour des dieux
qui agit
dans la dégagération
de la réconciliation
je ne peux pas
manquer d'amour
quand je manifeste
la paix
et la paix
c'est donc
le résultat naturel
de l'amour
je suis tellement
convaincu
que Dieu m'a aimé
comme un père
qu'il a donné son fils
pour moi
je ne peux plus douter
de ses bonnes intentions
envers moi
il a donné son fils
les créateurs
de l'univers
comment
il est en train
de planifier
pour moi
un futur encertain
c'est son amour
qui nous assure la paix
la joie
c'est cette joie
de la réconciliation
avec Dieu
c'est cette joie
qui est appelée
par certains puritains
comme la paix
qui danse
la joie inévitable
de savoir
qu'on a été pardonné
c'est la plus grande
remontée de l'univers
on a été enlevé
de l'enfer
avec toutes les punitions
qu'on méritait
de toutes nos crises
présentes
pour pouvoir être
déjà élevé
en esprit
aux régions célestes
et donc il n'y a
aucune autre chose
qui puisse mieux décrire
un homme en paix
avec Dieu
qu'à la joie
la patience
qui est tout simplement
une expression naturelle
de cette paix
envers les autres
car étant l'objet
de ces pardons
et de cette réconciliation
de Dieu
je ne peux pas agir
autrement
pour chercher
à promouvoir
donc prêcher
avec passion
confronter
les péchés
envisageant
la conversion
les saluts
ferveur
ne peut pas être
confondue
avec agressivité
animosité
des fois
on est en train
d'écouter
des prédicateurs
à la rue
parfois
ou même dans les poups
qui sont beaucoup
plus dans la colère
contre les perdus
qu'avec un coeur
compatissant
patient
et qui les exhorte
pour plaider
comme l'apôtre Paul
réconciliez-vous
avec Dieu
la patience
est donc une expression
d'un coeur
imprégné de paix
envers
des agents
et envers
des circonstances
qui parfois
veulent enlever
notre paix
même sous persécution
on prêche
avec ferveur
et patience
pour les saluts
des perdus
la bénignité
et la bonté
qui ont ces deux aspects
une qui est plutôt
ces chalons
de l'être
être l'image
de Dieu
être intègre
complet
donc être bon
quelque part
personne n'est bon
sinon Dieu
quand Jésus a dit ça
c'est pour dire
on n'a pas les chalons
si on n'a pas la conviction
qu'on est transformé
qu'on progresse
en sainteté
qu'on plaide Dieu
et donc bonté
c'est cette intégrité
et si on est sûr
qu'en Christ
on a cette intégrité
d'acceptation
et qu'on progresse
dans cette sainteté
dans la réalité
nous réjouissons
de plus en plus
de cette paix
et bien sûr
que cette paix
qu'on n'a pas méritée
qui nous a été offerte
elle va s'exprimer
par la bénignité
c'est-à-dire
la bonté
envers les autres
et donc c'est cette paix
qui est fondée
de ma réconciliation
avec Dieu
qui m'empêche
de ne pas être
autre chose
qui bénigne
envers les autres
c'est la parabole
du créditeur
en compatissant
qui n'a pas de compassion
qui a été pardonné
d'une dette
qu'il ne pouvait jamais
payer
et au moment
il sort
va demander une dette
infime
d'une autre personne
un chrétien
qui n'a pas
une attitude
de bénignité
fondée sur cette paix
sur cette réconciliation
envers les autres
il n'a pas compris
l'évangile
la fidélité
ou la fiabilité
ça parle
de cette constance
pourquoi la paix
doit être
une constance
pourquoi
car cette paix
qui a été assurée
pour nous
a été une paix
acquise
et conférée
de manière efficace
et perpétuelle
une fois acquise
impossible de perdre
réconciliation
fondée
sur l'oeuvre du Christ
une oeuvre parfaite
est-ce que nous sommes
cohérents
et fidèles
à cette paix
est-ce que nous sommes
fiables
dans l'exercice
de cette paix
il y a la douceur
qui c'est donc
tout simplement
l'attitude d'esprit
qui va marquer
tout ce qui a été
réconcilié avec Dieu
tout ce qui était conscient
d'être ennemi des dieux
de mériter la punition
des dieux
et qui au lieu
d'être traité
par la juste colère
des dieux
un dieux
qui prend sa colère
et qui la redirige
la dévie de nous-mêmes
pour la placer
en soi-même
dans la personne
de son fils
Roy Jones
il va dire
que celui
qui a déjà
échoué
celui qui a déjà
contemplé sa misère
il n'a pas peur
d'être traité
comme misérable
il n'a pas peur
de tomber
dans quel sens
il veut dire ça
c'est lorsqu'un chrétien
se trouve sous attaque
sous diffamation
il peut arriver à dire
vous avez raison
je suis misérable
j'étais même pire
tu as même oublié
plusieurs choses
que tu pourrais dire
à propos de moi
je peux être doux
je ne peux qu'être doux
car si
je dépendais de moi-même
pour
m'équiter de ma misère
ou pour
m'auto-promouvoir
ça n'aurait aucun sens
on n'est pas là
pour promouvoir
nous-mêmes
pour défendre
si on veut parler
de défendre notre justice
et notre droit
on devrait finir
à l'enfer
on est là
pour être
et pour porter
cette douceur
de l'agneau des dieux
de la brébie mouette
qui est allée porter
sur lui
nos souffrances
promouvoir
l'évolu de la paix
avec une attitude
douce
vers les autres
des relations légères
des relations faciles
par amour
conscient
que ceux qui nous attaquent
sont encore
esclaves
du manque de paix
des accusations
de la loi
de la manipulation
de Satan
esclaves du péché
de l'enfer
aveugles envers
les choses des dieux
ils ne peuvent qu'agir
de cette manière
envers nous
mais on a
la douceur du Christ
car on sait
qu'un jour
ils peuvent être aussi
l'objet de cette transformation
et c'est de cette manière
qu'on persiste
la paix
des dieux
donc
et c'est fondement
qui peut booster
la manifestation
équilibrée
et symétrique
de tous ces fruits
et nous devons être
intentionnellement
en train de nous dire
devant les confrontations
de la vie
pourquoi ces troubles
au mon âme
au-dedans de moi
exhorter sa propre âme
exhorter
les changements
et exercer
des comportements
au moment même
à l'instant
demandez vite
les pardons
au moment
vous avez raté
un petit moment
d'accès de colère
les plus tôt
on se concerte
on produit
des bons fruits
et puis
on se concerte
les plus tôt
!